ah man I think I think every stream
seems to start off like this where I get
like a a bunch of whites in a row here
let's try c4 I get I get nervous if it's
like three in a row so symmetrical
English so far so symmetrical and let's
keep going here and well we're gonna end
up with like a tirage there we go a lot
of tension here a3 we're both being
stubborn I play against we have this
variation I think the last stream last
stream I did I played somebody and we
were in this exact situation okay now
I'm gonna take now that the bishop has
moved play here I'm gonna take here or
just develop my bishop right away these
are my two candid nose takes or here if
I push here three to two majority but
then there's a two to one majority for
black I think I like
well no I'm gonna get my [ __ ] up here
first hang on decision time I might want
to be assured of a particular pond
structure that's why I'm taking pause to
this position if I do this then there
could be a capture I don't know if I
really want to allow that I mean let me
just run forward with it I want to
clarify the pawn structure now let's get
on this diagonal and I'm gonna play here
anticipating an eventual pin I want to
be in a spot to just be breaking in
castle or get a knight right here I
think I like doing this first one reason
for is because black is maybe ready to
play rook c8 and then conveniently meet
a knight b5 move with tucking the bishop
back to VA so now that I'm here I want
to do this move also before castling
because I think otherwise there might be
an a5 move and then the a file can open
up I don't know if I want to allow that
okay now I better Castle rook cc1 is
purposeful let's get there I have
control over this square which is a good
thing I could take this tonight I could
play Queen here I think I like Queen
here best let's go with that more
pressure on the night and maybe there's
ideas of taking the knight and then
playing bishop here which is maybe
picking up a pond so that's what that's
that's what I could be threatening right
now Knight takes followed by Bishop to
deform other purposeful moves might
include something like h3 just for for
what just for flight square purposes
being that there's still all mine all
major pieces on the board
um what else do I have available here
Knight takes a fault bite Bishop here
just seems too good to not do I'm gonna
do it he takes if pawn takes I still
play here and if pawn pushes then I
think eventually the dark square
business come off the board and then
mine I treat jumps right into this d4
square ah but before this I might want
to do this move yeah I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna try and get a little bit
squeezed a little bit more out of this
position before I play to d4 and you
know what maybe even playing Bishop here
right away isn't even needed the rep I'm
pretty sure has to just go back whoa was
this just missed what was I missing here
my opponent's going for well I don't
know what they're going for
that's this can't be right can it I just
take him the rook and I'm on the Queen
and I'm on the pond
it's very forcing I take the rook I'm on
the Queen Queen takes Queen takes pawn
I'm on the Queen even though there's
some tricks against this square I'm on
the Queen I don't see it and there is no
mate just yet I take here first
it'd be different if there was like
Knight takes Knight with check there and
now after Queen here I'm on the bishop
and the Queen I have to be cautious of
the removal of the defender this guy is
not reliable let's take the Queen so now
I kick the night away it's a flight
square and looking to simplify so I get
my Night Out f3 and then King here or
actually f3 and then pawn here first
just so I don't have to worry about a
knight h5 pivot and then getting to this
dark square so go with this first King
up to f2 if it's threatened with the
rook and there's not really a way to add
another attacker to that so I could do
this I'm on the pond there's another
Ford okay King up my knight is in a spot
to watch over this pawn and next up is
gonna be what this structure right here
these two pawns well really just this
pawn alone I know scratch that f3 and g4
constrain the knight take this night
away and
let's put more pressure on this there's
three pieces on this file so there's got
to be something happening okay get rid
of the LightScribe bishops how about
that let's go with this I really want to
get this pawn rollin to be a bit
cautious but oh okay wait what's the
story here let me do this I'm not sure
why exactly but minutes six minutes six
here
my Knights watching over the pond rookie
is met with rook a 1 there could be a
knight here
piling up on this but no I would just
take it Knight here I just take the nut
and then the bishop may be mine I could
do something else but let's do this
first rook takes rook mm-hmm
well I'm gonna go with this I'm dropping
this pawn or mi now I do this and then
after Bishop here I play Knight here and
if the knight moves then I hit this
Knight is there something better hang on
I just thinking throwing to check first
do not do that don't do that one right
here rook here attacking the pieces that
are defending okay
that Knight is actually out of squares
it's definitely out of squares that
night now what
just watch out for stalemates
no stalemates
if I take that pine it would have been
stalemate don't fall for stalemate okay
my opponent resigned there okay good
game let's hit that rewind button and
flip what's the what's the deal here
what's the scoop I think one thing as a
just getting really technical because
right here maybe black does best to
still play in some sense the mimicking
game right what I mean by that how about
just a six both of us should try to be a
bit more patient may be with deploying
our King Bishop because of the tension
going on between these pawns right here
and not wanting to move that Bishop
twice to recapture on the c4 and c5
squares so maybe a six instead I'm
feeling pretty comfortable to be honest
right now because I don't know if this
is I'm seeing it more as a liability
than an asset there's a wonderful
example game out there between well it's
it's a key route Rubenstein's immortal
where Rubinstein plays is black and
eventually acquires a position where
it's identical but black is all of a
sudden just playing as if they they had
the white pieces that they had an extra
move so in other words white white lost
time in that game and as a result
allowed for black to crashed through
with a flurry of very aggressive moves
and white was sure enough resigning in
that game
okay so anyhow that might be one too
even reference if you're if you're
looking to learn more I'll try and
reference this isn't something I was
always doing but if there's certain
games that I I think might be of
interest like if you're wanting to learn
more about it if you look up
Rubenstein's immortal I think you're
there's a lot more to learn about the
different ways to be gaining or losing
tempo out of this particular position
right here right here take a snapshot of
it King pawns both have moved a single
Square Queen Bishop on and queen pawn
both having gone two squares and the
Knights all of them are developed
classically these are considered the
classical squares for the Knights
so Rubenstein's immortal those are my
earliest points really to go with a six
right there instead of deploying the
bishop right away and maybe it's better
for the bishop to play here even though
it's not an annoying pin it is placing
the bishop in a position where you could
eventually trade itself off for my light
square bishop and then maybe as black
you couldn't be making use of the C 4
square a bit more easily I won't have
this guy around to watch over c4 it
might be one day a naive v 2 c4 type of
thing so maybe the bishops placement is
something else I do I do maintain
control over this isolated pawns so and
it's I think it's kind of tough to come
up with a constructive plan here is
black so Brooke back is probably best I
don't know I'm just up the exchange from
there and it's a technique time trying
to just convert the point but anyhow
those are my those are my quick points
nothing nothing elaborate
but um okay